a year of intense fighting in Ukraine
often hand to hand in muddy trenches has
taken a brutal psychological toll on a
military they're largely built of
volunteers many Ukrainian soldiers are
getting help now though at treatment
centers that identify and respond to
their PTSD symptoms Deborah patta shows
us how the centers are trying to limit
damage to the Soldier's mental health
before this war is over and we do warn
you before we roll This report it
includes disturbing images
[Music]
soothing music plays in a room based and
shifting pastel Shades
centered with the pleasant Aromas of
maybe Citrus and lavender
soldiers come here from the horrors of
the battlefield to this it may look like
a spa but in fact it is providing
desperately needed psychological first
aid to traumatize Fighters
this is therapy given during war instead
of after
along with a salt room for meditation
the center also offers yoga water sports
counseling even Sleep Therapy healing
battered bodies and bruised Hearts I'm
rather tired to kill another people
Andries on a week's break from defending
the besieged town of bakmut
a former businessman this father of two
has faced waves of Russian Wagner
Mercenaries
we can kill
10 20 50 of them but they shall try to
attack attack and attack our positions
the Ukrainian conflict has largely been
an artillery War but increasingly in the
East it's being fought at extremely
close quarters
actually it's very difficult to
to kill people in direct combat when you
are involved in a direct combat you
understood
you see you feel everything you see who
you've killed yes yes
he instinctively Dives for cover when he
hears a loud bang
and is tormented by dark repetitive
thoughts
I was tired I was rather nervous he was
desperate to talk to someone is it
easier or harder to go back to the
battlefield the a psychologist helped me
to
to clean to clean my mind a little
because it is not normally for us for
people to kill another it's not it's not
normally Andrei says he feels a little
better but a week is not enough
and a looming new Russian offensive has
already drawn head back to the front
lines
for CBS mornings Deborah patter Hartke
considering what these soldiers have
seen every little bit helps